ja scheiß drauf mach's einfach das
könnte man in meiner Sprache sozusagen
so sagen aber was ich eigentlich sagen
möchte ist wir sollten wieder ein
Perspektivwechsel vornehmen wir sollten
uns wieder mehr ins Positive mindset
bewegen das klingt alles sehr blumig was
ich jetzt sage weil es aber eigentlich
auch sehr einfach ist durch die
Klimakrise durch den Krieg durch Corona
sind wir Menschen ja durch die
Nachrichten und durch die Medien fast
täglich in dem negativen mindset
festgehalten wir hören nur Grusel
Nachrichten so und wenn wir das auch
noch in unserem normalen Alltag mit
reinnehmen dann wie sie sagen geht die
Spirale weiter runter das weiß ich sage
und das Phänomen des Anfang des Jahres
also der Januar ist ja immer der Monat
wo alle sagen okay jetzt nehme ich meine
großen Vorsätze jetzt setzt sich das um
dass ich abnehme dass ich gesünder esse
dass ich mich beruflich verändere was
auch immer und es interessant ist das
schon nach 14 Tagen im neuen Jahr
97% der Menschen die gute Vorsätze haben
diese wieder fallen lassen nur über drei
Magazin ist durch und dafür gibt es ganz
klare Gründer einmal dass man von sich
selbst zu wenig positiver
Erwartungshaltung hat und das zweite ist
die Menschen haben meistens kein klares
Ziel also die sagen ich nehme jetzt mal
abnehmen weil es ist auf Platz eins der
guten Vorsätze die sagen nicht ich
möchte in zehn Wochen 20 Kilo abnehmen
sondern wir sagen dieses Jahr wäre ich
jetzt mal jetzt fange ich mal ein
bisschen abzunehmen das zweite ist sie
haben keinen Plan selbst wenn Sie ein
Ziel haben machen sie sich keinen Plan
wenn ich sage okay in zehn Wochen möchte
ich gerne 20 Kilo abnehmen dann muss ich
mir einen Plan machen da muss ich in
einer Woche zwei Kilo abnehmen und am
Tag 285g habe ich den Plan nicht ist das
Ziel riesengroß und ich gehe bei den
eher beim ersten Gegenwind auf und das
dritte und das ist meiner Ansicht nach
entscheidend und da geht's nicht nur um
abnehmen oder um gesünder leben sondern
auch um berufliche Perspektiven um die
innere Balance mit sich selbst das
Commitment uns fehlt das Commitment und
selbst gegenüber wenn man sagt okay ich
habe das und das Ziel dann muss ich mich
auch mehr selbst gegenüber verpflichten
dass ich das so lange Verf nicht bis die
Zeit um ist sondern bis ich das Ziel
erreicht habe und das ist das was ich
sehr gerne kommuniziere nicht nur in den
Tanzschulen sondern auch in Vorträgen
und das ist das Thema was ich heute
mitgebracht habe Frau wagenbech können
Sie auch zu den 97 Prozent haben sich
irgendwas vorgenommen nicht eingehalten
nee also so richtig viel vorgenommen
also sag mal die Sachen die mir für
dieses Jahr vorgenommen habe die sind
noch nicht abzurechnen die sind erst
eher für den Herbst geplant
aber ich sag mal so ich glaube ich bin
was Selbstdisziplin angeht noch
einigermaßen also versuche ich mich zu
strukturieren aber ich verstehe das
natürlich auch immer viele Leute haben
ja auch ein enormen Stresslevel also
weil einfach jetzt ganz viel zusammen
kommt ne man hat man hat einmal die so
ständig steigenden Preise da hat man
dann muss man dann auch schon wieder
gucken was kaufe ich überhaupt das ist
ja auch ernähre mich gesund klingt ja
immer gut wenn man sie abnehmen will
muss man sich gesund ernähren ja vieles
was gesund ist ist auch so teuer also
man muss sich was leisten können da muss
man viel Disziplin haben gerade wenn es
einem dreckig geht ich kenne das auch
man ist irgendwie müde abends man hatte
nächsten Tag Stress und dann steht da
irgendwie eine ganze Tafel Schokolade
oder ein toller Kuchen ja man belohnt
sich auch also das heißt wenn man
irgendwie im Stress ist und im Druck ist
dann macht man auch Dinge die man dann
vielleicht bereut und ich glaube so geht
es einfach vielen Leuten total legitim
ja deswegen sage ich immer der Weg zum
Erfolg wenn wir jetzt über gesunde
Ernährung sprechen ist eine Sinuskurve
ist nicht linear das heißt es geht mal
hoch und mal runter ich habe vor
mittlerweile 10 Jahren 32 Kilo
abgenommen 14 Wochen das ist nämlich
auch faszinierend wenn man sie früher
sieht und heute sie sieht böse Patricia
auf meinem auf böse jetzt nicht
irgendein dicken Bild von mir zeigen
ganz kurz mal ganz kurz mal aushaltendes
trotzdem weg
[Gelächter]
werden sie sich da motiviert also wie
baut man da dran genau das was ich
gerade gesagt habe ich hatte ein klares
Ziel und ich habe mit jedem darüber
gesprochen auch diejenigen die es nicht
hören wollten ich habe gesagt ich will
aufs Cover einer Fitnesszeitschrift und
dafür müssen sich mindestens 20 Kilo
abnehmen das wollte ich in zehn Wochen
abnehmen und glauben Sie mir viele haben
über mich gelacht viele haben gesagt ja
so ist der Mario Bart hat immer gesagt
der Dicke Tanzlehrer aus dem Osten ja so
niemand hat es geglaubt aber das hat
mich natürlich motiviert weiter zu
machen dann hatte ich einen klaren Plan
ich wusste was ich am Tag abnehmen muss
und ich habe eingepreist das ist auch
mal Niederlagen das ist Rückschläge gibt
also fragen Sie mal meine Kinder oder
meine Frau wie oft ist nachts passiert
ist das plötzlich auf dem Kissen ähm
Schokoladenflecken waren weil ich nachts
wie ein Zombie runter bin und unsere
Küche und das schokoladenfach der Kinder
aufgemacht habe und eine ganze Tafel Weg
gegessen habe aber wenn du diese
Rückschläge einplanst ja Erfolg ist
nicht Sinus hoch mal runter dann bist du
nicht mehr überrascht und gibt's nicht
so schnell auf weil du weißt okay war
klar das ist passiert weitermachen
jetzt bei ihnen anderen sie sich
irgendwas vorgenommen und fühlen Sie
sich jetzt motiviert wenn sie so diese
paar Stichpunkte die er so ist uns jetzt
reingegeben hat hören ja tatsächlich und
es ist wirklich ein gutes Thema weil
genau wie du gesagt hast es ist wichtig
ist nicht der wichtig keine Ahnung ich
möchte erfolgreich sein ich möchte viel
Geld verdienen das ist so konkret wie
möglich ich möchte in einer halben Jahr
das und das machen deswegen hat mir das
Beispiel nicht unbedingt wegen des
Fitness Magazins aber wegen der
Bildhaftigkeit gut gefallen denn ich
möchte dieses Fitness Magazin ich möchte
keine Ahnung bei dieser Zeitung
publizieren ich möchte
Ihre persönlich sehr privat
natürlich
schon
oder ich muss jetzt das Dankeschön kurz
übersetzen
Visualisierung die du gerade ansprichst
ja was ich gemacht habe Leute haben
darüber gelacht ich habe mir aus einer
Fitnesszeitschrift als ich angefangen
habe mit diesem Abnehmprozess im Bild
von einem männlichen auch dunklen
fitnessmodel rausgerissen was mit
Badehose aus dem extra mit dem Sixpack
kam und hatte das dann immer in meinen
Portemonnaie mit drin und manchmal habe
ich im Flieger gesessen Mittelsitz links
ein Mann rechts ein Mann und ich packe
währenddessen dann mein Bild aus und
guck mir die ganze Zeit das Passage
aufgemacht aber aus anderen Gründen
du weißt was ich meine ja also diese
Visualisierung ist extrem wichtig nicht
was will ich nicht mehr sondern was ist
das was ich will was ist mein Ziel wo
will ich landen das ist doch als
Strategieberater das ist doch deine
richtige Strategie gute Strategie also
ich finde es super
ich bin auch toll ich versuche auch was
zu machen
in der Tat ich glaube die Routine ich
glaube das ist die Routine ich stehe
morgen jeden Morgen früher auf und dann
sage ich Dir jeden morgen mache ich das
jetzt einfach jeden Morgen
ich versucht und wenn ich es noch nicht
gemacht habe hole ich diesen Tag nach
das heißt ich versuche quasi immer das
abzuhaken dann gibt's auch Apps über das
helfen können generell was eigentlich
noch toll finde wäre wenn Prominente
allgemein prominente sagen würden das
ist mein Fitnessziel ich mache bestimmte
Dinge als Leute quasi folgen also quasi
dazu sagen sollen so direkt intensive
daraus Deutschland wenn du gute Idee und
dann können wir sie auf andere Bereiche
auch noch ausweiten und nicht daran
körperliche Gewicht verlassen das ist
das neue Buch das war nur noch gesehen
denn wir haben dich umsonst hier in der
Sendung scheiß drauf gesagt das ist halt
einfach machen und einfach loslegen
bleibst du in einer Passivität und das
ist frustrierend weil du nicht wegkommst
vom Fleck und und das schaffst
Frustration wenn du anfängst dich zu
bewegen ob es kleine Schritte oder sind
oder große ist erstmal egal aber wenn du
in die Bewegung gehst wenn du ins
Handeln kommst dann merkst du das Dinge
sich verändern und es gibt dir den Mut
weiter zu machen